I have to agree with the um you can find  a better baby mother because I think  there's more good women than there are  good men  so yeah I could agree with that there  are more good women than there are good  men yeah what makes you say that and  what's your statistical data on that and  what is the version it's not it's just  my opinion it's not statistics it's not  is it because of the men you deal with  um no I'm married so it's not the men I  deal with I'm just curious what like why  is that your opinion on man  um because it's just my opinion I think  there are well for one there's more  women in the world so you're probably  going to find more good women than you  are going to find good men